there's like schools of sailfish coming
through like they're just swarming under
the belt right now swarming
what was that
launching
[Music]
oh it's running it's running left it's
round left
my heart's pounding
but every time i try to get it near the
boat he makes a big surge and takes line
out now we're fishing then now we're
fishing
i'm a freshwater pro but this saltwater
fight is next level damn this fish is
going crazy
i'm mike iaconelli my friends and i grew
up fishing the mean streams and rivers
of philadelphia
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all it takes is a little skill and a
local let's go to show you where the
fish are biting
[Music]
this week we're in miami florida
in a lot of cities it can be hard to
find water
but not here in miami this place is
surrounded by water
oceans on that side freshwater canals on
this side and that means tons of fish
because of that
i'm doubling down double the fun
double the fish
i'm going to challenge myself to
catching three of miami's beautiful
freshwater exotics
and three of miami's saltwater classics
first up in the freshwater i'm going for
the weed eating grass carp all three of
my exotics have made themselves right at
home in miami's tropical climate and the
grass carp is no exception
these things were introduced from asia
in 1975 to control the invasive weed
hydrilla since they go for grass they
can be pretty tricky to catch with bait
but i love the challenge and i know the
perfect local to give me a hand today i
have a good friend of mine monster mike
he's the ultimate street fisherman he's
going to guide me on these freshwater
canals in miami and we're going to try
to catch all three species
in one day
mike
mike
what's up man
good to see you guys thank you again
mike i got the impossible challenge for
us today and what's that
we need to catch three different species
today
peacock bass grass carp
and then finally midas cichlid any
chance we can get it done in one day we
will catch all three species today is
there an order we're gonna attack them
what's the deal first we're gonna go to
these grass carp we got some bread we're
using bread for grass we're gonna use
bread let's do it man let's do it let's
get started
there's plenty of grass and weeds in
these canals so getting grass carp to
take the bait on hook and line is gonna
be tough
tell me a little bit how how did you get
started in this whole thing well when i
was three years old my dad started me
off young ever since then you know i
just been my number one hobby something
that i loved all my free time i just put
into fishing time isn't something i have
a lot of for this challenge so i need to
really think about what i'm fishing with
these grass carp are smart they're line
shy they're line sensitive so i'm going
to use real light fluorocarbon the fish
don't detect it they don't know it's
there they don't even feel the presence
of the line it's so light
it's got a six pound breaking point so
watch this
easily i can break it just by going like
that
fighting a fish on six-pound models it's
gonna be it's gonna be fine it's gonna
be it's gonna be one good fight can't
wait
grass carp grow fast up to two pounds
per month large adult fish usually sit
between 15 and 20 pounds
but there's reports of these things
growing as big as 100 pounds maybe
that's all the bread i'm gonna chum up
the waters oh i see one i see one
already you see one already that's him
dude yep we're gonna that's a giant
cast
in the in the middle that's right there
yeah oh perfect perfect perfect
perfect let let that sink
did you turn oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
i think you're good
oh my god no
okay next time we're gonna wait a little
longer okay i missed okay oh he hated it
don't know it's all good it's all good
seeing the grass carp sneak up on the
bait like that is nerve-wracking i
popped my cork and i tried to set the
hook too soon god okay let's do this
thing can i just do that we both just
did that because we we thought it was i
should have waited a little bit more
until i felt them we'll wait next time
here they come here they come i see them
see good good okay okay okay
i see him oh my god look at the size of
that one oh they're they're the school
the school
oh i think he's on you so let let him
run with it did he yeah i see you're
lying moving
yeah it's game time let's get this fit
oh they're by you
he's got it
yes
nice now take nice
nice
i'm gonna go i'm gonna go grab the net
that's giant too
i've only got this fish because i used
an almost invisible thread of
fluorocarbon
he's trying to get me yeah
you're good
beautiful fish
but now i wish i had something much
stronger
six pound line yes
this thing's got to weigh at least 15
pounds
you're good
oh look at the size yes he's a monster
okay straight in straight in
straight in get it like straight out
that's too small no it's not it's not
too small it's not too small we're going
to get them
mike bring him in
we got him hey get it
you got him
we got him
[Applause]
look at that thing that is a beautiful
oh my gosh
that is the asian grass carp these
things eat three times their body weight
every day
that's a lot of vegetation to get
through it all their teeth have been
replaced by specialized structures
called pharyngeal teeth
these sit in the back of their throat
and help tear and grind down plant
matter
they can live over 10 years or more
in these canals
man what a fight
on light lines that's fantastic that's a
big fish for a freshwater canal like
and it's my first freshwater fish catch
in miami grab them hold them by the tail
if you can
here it goes
awesome
we're fishing the cutler drain canal
these neighborhoods are built around
canals
imagine being able to fish from your own
back door
and they keep people safe too
this place is a former swamp that's
sitting in hurricane alley
these canals were built more than 50
years ago to help return storm water to
the sea more than 2 000 miles of them
crawling with fish
my next bucket list fish is the
beautiful midas cichlid another foreign
traveler soaking up the sun and heat in
miami it was probably an accidental
aquarium release first spotted in these
canals in 1980
nice i see one is that that the orange
fish that's the yep that orange fish
some more back in the middle that's the
miter cichlid so look this one
oh that's a good one too we just ate
that give me your hook give me your hook
all right little hook tiny tiny tiny
hook
casser right there there's a bunch
these things are omnivores and they're
very territorial
if i can get this bread in front of them
they might get agitated enough to bite
oh yeah yeah they're rushing to your
bread
here oh he's on it wait
[Music]
wait
wait
you got him
you had him
we're going to get him again
you've been the worst
no i get out of there
i never felt them
these things are tricky i'm getting hot
yeah
i got to take my backpack off i'm
getting hot
oh you see what they're doing look see
what they're doing
wait
big bluegill
wow
that thing
all right now that's not a midas that's
not a midas look at that
dude that is a bluegill
now you know we're fishing for a lot of
exotics today yeah but this is actually
a native
to north america into this part of
florida and just so you know the
bluegill is the state fish of illinois
but we're in florida yeah so we're just
gonna put it back
oh you oh there's a big one on you
midas get as big as nine inches so this
guy's a whopper oh yeah that's a big one
too i can see him in there oh one's
chasing it
i just can't catch him
[Music]
he was it wasn't
i never felt him i'm only on to my
second freshwater fish and i don't want
to fail already it's just all bad
man i'm in miami canal fishing with my
friend monster mike oh you oh there's a
big one on you
recast recast it out
for these freshwater midas cichlid and
so far it's just all bad man
i've yet to strike gold well they never
scooped it up huh there's three goodens
down there they're all oh there's that
big hunchback coming oh my gosh
down yeah
okay here he comes here he comes full
speed wait
wait
wait
wait
oh you got it
yeah
you got him oh that's a big one too big
biters work him this is a midas oh i'll
i'll get them from over there it's a
midas that's a big midas watch out for
the trees
look at that fish
oh man that's a giant big minus
come
oh my gosh look how bright orange look
at that
it's brightly colored and has a
pronounced hump on its head
the hump gets larger around breeding
times march through may is midas peak
spawning season
mike i don't know if you knew this yeah
but these midas are super aggressive
dude they've been known to kill their
mate wow and when these things are in
aquariums they'll actually chase people
they'll chase pets they'll bang their
head against the aquarium glass those
are some vicious creatures people think
they have to travel to catch exotic fish
but we're right we're in miami all right
let's let this thing go i'm gonna go
back down on that rock and let it go yep
look at him look at him look at it there
he goes there he goes
awesome mike
in just under three hours i've already
caught two out of my three miami
freshwater fish
the grass carp and the midas cichlid
this is urban fishing miami style right
now we're headed to the spot to catch my
final freshwater fish the peacock bass
look at that
an actual peacock
this has to be a good sign i'm in miami
to catch peacock bass and i see a
peacock bird
you don't see these things roaming the
streets of philadelphia but in miami
this is a common sight
pifal are native to india and sri lanka
they were probably brought to miami as
exotic pets they're loud and they make a
lot of mess so people either love them
or hate them
but they're no threat to the peacock
bass
[Music]
so they don't bug me dude this is this
is urban fishing look at this little
thing
fences and pipes when's the last time
you jumped with him remember
oh my gosh look look look look look
there's a bunch there's a bunch
look at that big one right there right
at the base of the tree yes
got it i'm old mike
got it not not too old although it's
another cichlid the peacock bass is
shaped like a bass and has a golden ring
on its cottle fin like a peacock
these things are known for being great
fighters
they're also aggressive predators that
fiercely protect their young
guarding them for up to 10 weeks and
chasing off any would-be attackers
so they've got an area they're being
territorial or they've got an actual bed
where they're getting ready to lay eggs
when these peacocks get in that mode
they're very protective putting this
little shiner by them a lot of times it
makes them mad they come out and eat it
and you got them
walk walk to the end and let's look walk
to the end i think our visual will be
better and we'll be closer to the fish
let's just see let's just see
look that one in the middle is pretty
nice just do a free cast and just see if
he'll eat
oh oh this is it
dude how does he do a circle on it like
that now get it
the water's so clear i can see my bait
the little shiner working its magic
this kind of fishing gets my heart
pumping oh gosh oh gosh oh gosh this the
shiner's doing the right stuff okay here
it is
here it goes here it goes
[Music]
that's a monster
did he take your hook
[Music]
i gotta go put a bigger leader on
broke my gun three places too
oh and the rod broke all right take a
break
okay so i'm annoyed at myself the
peacock bass is known for its lightning
strike and with all the wood pipes and
rock that can snag in this creek i'm
gonna need some extra tough line called
leader and it's attached between the
lure and the main line that won't snap
so easily
yeah it happens it happens hey this is
called being under matched is what
that's called
i mean i got such a disaster here using
real light leader
you know sometimes it's too light
so i just took a moment i re-tied
now i've got 17-pound leader on they're
not gonna break that one
so get another hook tied on we're gonna
keep trying
i gotta bone the pick with this fish yes
it's personal now now it's perfect it's
very personal yep i know the feel
[Music]
oh you got him
[Music]
no no no be careful
here
yes we got him revenge we got him
revenge is so sweet
oh wait wait that's a giant wait
i got to show you something uh-oh
uh-oh what's we talked about revenge
right look in his mouth your hook get
your hook back mike my other hook
look at this here's one hook here's the
hook i caught him on yep
and what's in his another hook there's
the other hook
i got my other hook back i'll hold that
wow i'm gonna keep this for a souvenir
look at that thing the peacock bass
native of south america yep brought here
in 1984
and they put them in these canals to
help get rid of a lot of the exotics the
small invasive and exotic species
they adapt it perfectly to this part of
florida south florida near miami you go
any further north it's too cold and they
die out but in the shallow clean canal
system they are killing machines
look how big and wide big mouth that
mouth is
and i can tell you something yep mike
i've been tournament fishing for 20
years i catch a lot of largemouth bass
these things fight three times harder
than any largemouth i've ever caught in
my life they fight hard hard fighting
fish right there that is a gorgeous fish
look at that thing
what do you think should we let it go
let's let it go they say anglers spend
more than eight million dollars per year
in the hopes of catching one of these
things
and i could see why
that is a gorgeous fish look at that
thing
i've been in miami one day and i've
caught all three of my freshwater fish
but i want to experience miami full
flavor it's time to add some salt
it's another beautiful day in miami
yesterday i caught all three of my
freshwater miami exotics
[Music]
the grass carp
the midas cichlid
and the peacock bass
florida is known as the fishing capital
of the world
no fisherman worth of salt would leave
miami without fishing at saltwater
classics and i'm going for three the
snook
the sailfish and the silver king the
tarpon first up is the snook
the best way to describe snook
it's like a largemouth bass of the sea
peak feeding times for the snook are two
hours before sunrise and two hours after
sunset
that gives me some time to kill
since i'm fishing at night i'm gonna
need some coffee
some cuban coffee
i'm headed to the suburb of little
havana
in the 1950s fidel castro led a
successful armed revolt against the
government of cuba known as the cuban
revolution
the revolt led to sweeping changes and
miami became the hub for cuban exiles
fleeing the country
today the area remains a celebration of
cuban culture
and in 2017 the national trust for
historic preservations declare little
havana a national treasure
i've had enough cuban espresso to last
all night long and i'm ready to hook me
a snook
[Music]
i'm gonna go meet a friend of mine from
back in the day named dave and we're
gonna do a little night fishing for a
monster snook a long time no see man
good to see you good to see you how are
they biting we got a chance to catch
some we got a little cold front in here
northeast wind but we should be able to
get it done
this cold front could make things a
challenge
snook are temperature sensitive and
prefer warmth
i'm hoping this wind lets up there's
already a lot going on out here
you know you talk about urban fishing
city fishing
doesn't get any more urban than this
miami florida south beach
shipping containers noise traffic boats
people
this is city fishing
tonight we're headed out through
government cut
a man-made waterway that was dug through
land for easier access to miami port
now miami has one of the busiest cruise
ports in the world
i just hope that the snooker using it
too
this to me is getting to be prime time
the sun is setting
it's getting dark
i'm not an expert on snook fishing but
the one thing i know
is that at night is when you catch the
really big snook
a snook has the very distinct black
lateral line super dark black lateral
line running down its body
it uses that lateral line to detect
vibrations
so even something as subtle as that
little paddle tail
vibrate in the water
those snook are going to be able to hunt
that out in complete darkness and find
that bait
i think
maybe
i don't know
oh
[Music]
another little bite
second little bite ahead
i don't know what they are if they're
like
snook are gonna be like
you know
you know you're gonna be like oh god
you think it'd be quiet out here very
little traffic but it's the opposite
it's hopping out here
everything from giant commercial liners
to little tiny small dinghies
everybody's out here
i guess
you know on a weekend in miami it's
hopping everywhere even on the water
snook like a lot of fish are easily
spooked
shadows big splashes loud noises can all
be enough to drive these lurking
predators into hiding
and it probably explains why i'm getting
no bites
we're doing a little bit of spot hopping
we've switched to the other side of the
jetty a little bit more protected
sometimes the current runs a little
different
still throwing big swim baits
and nothing to show
it's uh these fish can be fickle
a lot of it's about timing and tide
so our tide is switched
hopefully it's coming back now
and maybe that'll start triggering this
bite
moving water triggers snook to feed so
water movement from a change in the tide
will hopefully mean a change in my
fortunes
come on fish
man
it's rough we've been out here all night
and i hate to admit it but
tonight we've been defeated
it's funny because of fishing sometimes
the easiest fish
become the hardest
and that was the case tonight
but i'm not ready to totally give up
they call miami the magic city and i
think it can deliver
tonight it was cold it was noisy but i'm
willing to do whatever it takes to win
this
i'm going to use my phone to friend
option and call monster mike
hello
mike
hey what's up what's up it's ike
i went out it was just one of those
nights where nothing worked man i mean
that condition with the big boat and the
weather yeah that throws it off
especially for snow fishing do you have
any dudes here in miami that are dialed
with snook yes i got a guy named ryan
i'll give him a call right now and let's
let's make it happen let's let's let's
conquer this cool mike i appreciate it
thanks man
it's an hour before dawn in miami and
i'm up before the birds
i've given myself one more chance to
catch one of my saltwater fish to snook
i barely got a bite last night so i'm
hooking up with monster mike's buddy
ryan
how you doing good to meet you nice to
meet you you ready for this i'm ready
we're headed north out into the calm
morning waters of biscayne bay right off
of downtown
miami this is one of the coolest parts
of the day
idle and out of the harbor
sunrise in the background pink skies
and then skyscrapers in the back
pretty pretty special that that's what
makes city fishing really special
but it can make it problematic too
for years human development affected the
health of biscayne bay
in the 1960s and 70s conservationists
fought hard to have the bait cleaned up
it's now a national park and home to
loads of aquatic species like the snook
they're here i just need to catch one
what are we fishing here swim baits or
babe i'll do live bait do a couple cast
live bait and then we'll switch cool
this little dock has a
rock sea wall and the light shines in
the water so at night they sit on the
light so they might be holding staging
still there yeah we'll take a couple
casts of the bridge we'll work the
seawall give a couple minutes since
they're not here we'll keep moving
if a snook wants the bait it'll find it
these things have an acute sense of
vision and smell
add that black lateral line into the mix
and you've got a triple threat
i'm ready to assault all three snook
senses using this live bait
the thing about
a spot like this is
we've got a dock near an area where it
necks down in front of a bridge and this
dock has two lights shining down in the
water
at night or even early in the morning
like this those lights are attractors
for the bait fish
and anywhere there's a lot of bait
you're gonna find saltwater game fish
like the snook
what are the bites like on this bait uh
you'll feel it though
last night i barely felt a tickle let
alone a thump
i'm starting to get nervous i can't have
the same thing happen today i want that
snook
all right what do you think yeah we'll
make a move
there may be no bites at this spot but
biscayne bay is a nearly 40-mile long
lagoon
that's a lot of places to look for a
snook
and they're not the only thing to make a
home in the preserve waters
we also need to keep our eyes open for
manatees
boat strikes are the most common human
cause of death for these things
they're marine relatives to the elephant
and can grow to weigh over 3 000 pounds
they gain all that weight from eating
sea grasses and fresh water vegetation
that kind of gives me an idea
yeah we made a made a small move and
we're going to fish an area that's
basically a grass flat
you know vegetation man is the attractor
of life so
we've got big flat out here in front of
the sea wall it's got grass on it that
grass is going to attract the bait the
crabs and then that stuff uh attracts
the game fish and hopefully there'll be
a few snook in this grass
the grass sticks out about 10 15 feet
and it drops off
we're uh we're on our second step
i'm coming
there he is going
oh god what is that
is that a snook
come on stay on there stay on there stay
on there stay on there
i'm really really scared to try to horse
this thing in on this slight braid
want to take my time this i'm pretty
sure this is a snook
it's fighting amazing look at the rod
tip totally bent light tackle
real real light tackle light spinning
rod
get that thing in there yeah
wow
look at that
there you have it i was super nervous
and worried
this is the snook
one of the nicknames for this snook is a
line cider and that's because of that
really dramatic black line
that goes down the side of its body
you know it's interesting as these
things grow
this species eats bigger and bigger prey
so as these fish get to 10 20
30 pounds they could eat bigger prey
you know in the past the snook was known
as a soap fish
because when you're cooking improperly
the taste of a snook is very soapy but i
don't need to worry about that i've
caught them and now i'm going to release
them
that's fine we need a big one now yeah
knocked it off
hey
monster mike said best snook guy in all
miami
he was right
bird's not even awake yet oh my gosh
[Music]
i'm in miami working through one of my
toughest challenges yet catching six
fish in one city
i've caught four there's two to go
today i'm going for the miami saltwater
classic the fastest fish in the ocean
the mighty sailfish
this thing's gotta be on every angler's
bucket list
i'm gonna need all the help i can get
[Music]
my friend and three-time sailfish
champion peter miller is just the man
for the job i see you too how's
everything miami's treating you well
miami's treat me great finally we get
the fish together this is actually the
condition you want we have a north wind
okay we've got a north current they
converge and they mount up a little
swell the sailfish tailed down sea
they're swimming against it so they're
gobbling like pac-man pop-pop wow these
things are a prized catch known for
their tremendous fight they can grow to
over 200 pounds i'm jacked i can't talk
about it maybe either can we get on the
phone no let's go let's go meet quentin
i know by the way the outfit
the epitome of sartorial elegance right
there that well that is conducive to
sailfish i always say in fishing you
gotta match the hatch sailfish spend
most of their time near the surface of
the water
when they feed they use their sail-like
dorsal fins to herd schools of fish and
then stun them using their bills
sailfish to strike you want the bait
near the surface and you want it alive
and it doesn't get much more alive than
this
so this fella here mike he's been
delivering bait forever today we're
getting big goggle eyes
all right i got that look at that that's
a low debate right there some pilchards
keep it coming
more pilchers and some threadfins
complete our sailfish smorgasbord a lot
of important people today
but that guy right there very important
ariel the bait guy he's the mvp ariel
may be the mvp but pete's about to
unleash the day's real high flyer
you got me too
yeah whenever you're at it all right
i've never been kite fishing but pete's
the master
he connects a baited drop line to the
kite
that's right we clip that sucker in like
this
kite fishing is great because while it
keeps the bait sitting just under the
surface where we want it it keeps the
line out of the water so it won't scare
the fish
when a fish bites the fishing line
unclips from the kite line and it's back
to good old-fashioned muscle power
you know when there's bait in the area
like that they're gonna they're gonna
come they've got
all these species have incredible senses
that they're using to find this bait
and the sailfish is no exception as well
as great eyesight in that lateral line
they may be able to communicate while
hunting schools of fish by changing
color and flashing iridescent stripes on
their skin
a bit like a strobe light it sounds like
these fish like the party
my name is mike
whoa i can know it
run it's a sailfish
good reel
what was that
sailfish let him run let it run
that's how you do it man
the beat fox brought the fish to the
yard good job dude nice and easy nice
and easy
let him run
so you got a sailfish right off the
coast of miami where it was like a mile
offshore
yeah you're gaining right
yeah he's backing up for you
here's another one pete
hold on hold on he sees another one
coming off the bow
schools of sailfish coming through like
hot dude that was 10 fish there
they're they're swarming under the belt
right now swarming
i'm on hooked up doubleheader coming up
jumping over here way hard this is
fishing on steroids
pete's hooked a fish i've hooked a fish
and my fish is putting up one hell of a
fight
[Applause]
we're using circle hooks rather than
getting swallowed the hook catches in
the corner of a fish's mouth
it's safer for the fish but it's
destroying my nerves
[Applause]
this fish is really fighting for its
life but i'm not going to hurt it
launching
get the release on that one pete ready
getting ready for the release this tag
needs the pliers the circle hook in the
corner of its mouth is unlikely to cause
it any harm
pete's fish is a beauty all he needs to
do now is cut the line got the release
and his fish is free
swimming away right in the prop wash
which is good
because i need all the help i could get
my knuckles are on fire
all right it's getting closer it's
getting closer guys pete just tell me
what i need to do all right you're doing
great you're doing great are we going to
actually try to get this thing in the
boat no well no you're not allowed to
listen to unless you want to keep them
but you're going to wind to the court
the idea is for you to get that cork to
the tip of the rod with a leader
touching that's a legal release okay or
me touching it one time is a legal
release okay
so it counts it counts pulling the
sailfish out of the water after an
exhausting fight can be deadly to these
incredible species
if you do the national marine fishery
service can slap you with a hefty fine
a legal release means you can catch
these fish without pulling them out of
the water
dude it is
one of the strongest fish i've ever
caught my heart's pounding
i'm so close i can see the fish
but every time i try to get it near the
boat he makes a big surge and takes line
out all i'm thinking right now
is i want to get to that leader
if we get to that leader and touch that
leader it's considered a legal fish
you're almost there just reel down right
now touch it reel down go down and you
go legal it's
this is my first sailfish ever and it's
a giant
get the release on that one pete ready
getting ready for the release got the
release
got it
[Music]
well we got to give it the spin when we
get the sail
the captain's doing a spin and just like
in nascar
when the winner wins the race they do a
burnout
we're doing a spin we're doing it
[Applause]
that is a celebration
that's how you do it
i'm in miami fishing my craziest
challenge yet
six fish in five days
i've caught them all bar one
it's 1 30 am and i'm going out to catch
the silver king the mighty tarpon
[Music]
this is an important day because if it
doesn't happen today
it's all over tomorrow afternoon i'm on
a plane and i'm headed back to a
tournament i'm about to meet miami's
king of tarpon fishing russell russ
what's going on mike how you doing doing
great how are you good to see you
absolutely good to see you today's an
important day for me it's literally my
last opportunity i only have one left
and it is the silver king all the
conditions are right the stars are lined
up so we're gonna try to get you your
big tarpon
this prized game fish was first caught
using a rod and reel right here in
florida on sanibel island in 1885.
the catch revolutionized the sport
word of their mighty fight brought
anglers far and wide ready to try their
luck in catching the silver king
i'm willing to do whatever it takes to
land one of these monster fighters
we're getting a super early start here
is it because we're fishing night
because these fish are smart
they're smart but they're very old and
they have really good eyesight
old is an understatement the tarpon is a
member of an ancient group of fish whose
fossil records date back to the jurassic
period
they may be ancient but their vision is
sharp
human eyes have three color detecting
cone cells whereas tarpon have five
we use nighttime and darkness and
anything that gained an advantage right
that's why i fissured a red headlight
only i put no ambient light in the water
right the color red is absorbed and gets
lost faster underwater than any other
color so it's our best bet for staying
out of sight of the tarpon we're getting
close to this spot we're moving to ninja
mode
blacked out
night ops yep redhead light yep
quiet danger quiet that's it's how i
fish okay
we've just snuck into the secret hole
we've got all the lights out russ is
back there right now baiting it up and
we are loaded with bait we've got
everything from shrimps to crabs to
goggle eyes
we've got everything necessary to catch
a tarpon on our first stop
adult tarpon feed on fish and
crustaceans like crabs and shrimp
using their big mouths they tend to
swallow their prey whole
i hope the same goes for my bait
it may be dark out here but using a fish
finder is like having x-ray vision a
couple fish on the left there mike right
towards you ireland
oh
ah i'm hooked up already
literally my first drop
walk to the back mike
big fish he's going up on the flat i've
hooked the tarpon and it's racing away
with my line get ready he's gonna freak
out he's coming back he's coming back at
you fast
so just get ready for some mayhem he's
running right at you
walk up here mike walk up here oh my god
i just saw it for the first time i just
saw a jump you got a big one get around
me get around me
[Music]
is this a fish or is this a big mac
truck that i have on
i'm not sure
these things can get as big as 350
pounds
this is a really big fish
i'm assuming this is a big tarpon
all these fish fight different
some make jumps
some dive
this one has not turned its head yet
it's taken a tremendous amount of drag
we got a danger zone coming up so i got
to pay attention here
we're sitting in deep water listen to me
see that slick there's a ridge right
there it goes from like 15 to four feet
the backside's 26 if he goes over and
burns us off he'll drop in the hole and
break our line
oh god
it was
it looked like a dinosaur
oh
it's definitely a tarpon it's definitely
the silver king
look at it look at it look at it
there he is yeah yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
one of the biggest fish i've ever caught
in my entire life 45 years walking the
face of the earth a true giant of the
salt water
right here in miami look at the size of
that eye
five cones it's got some of the best
vision of anything that swims in the
ocean
keep her in the water let her go it's
got enough oxygen she's ready to go back
i'll reach down when she's vertical and
cut her off like that watch watch watch
watch watch there she goes away look at
that
that's how you let him go healthy yeah
yeah rough i didn't think i could do it
but miami you have delivered six bucket
list fish in five days
it's been an unbelievable
life-changing experience thank you miami
dude awesome
unbelievable see what time that is right
there first cast dude did that just
happen yeah no no
[Music]
[Music]
you